I just got out of the elevator that's
weird
I think that's so funny well it's the
only article I think that came out yeah
you ready we're gonna reenact guys
babban did a terrible job didn't capture
this like sit they've got one basic job
and I'm not wrong right like it's like
hey you fill me now I know I
transitioned from another room but
nonetheless these guys are like hey did
you hear about the Facebook baseball
game and I was like making pretend that
I didn't I was like I made them look at
my Twitter account because I tweeted it
a minute earlier it was pretty much the
greatest moment of my day thank you
[Music]
how's it going brother Corsi me no
worries man oh okay
so I hey you know obviously but you're
all over the Internet sighs yes
somewhere yes but you know on a stick I
never like I totally get it look good
yeah
and I was gonna I went to Colombia
because I needed like inspiration right
and Colombia the country keep going and
I love Latin music yes energy of Latin
music and I was out there and I was
hanging out with these girls and they
kept saying I'm Nicky Jam I'm Nicky Jam
now my walk is this guy Nicky Jam so so
they play the song X I came out and I'll
say oh [ __ ] this is not high so then I
started looking into this dude I'm like
ya know what what's making like these
girls go crazy friend and then I
stumbled across our interview with him
yeah your interview I'm like damn then I
started looking into it more than I
remember wait a minute this is a meal it
would work for you I'm like I need a I
need this guy that's cool huh because I
watched an interview and I was like man
like he's saying some legit [ __ ] I'd
appreciate a man I took a trip to Cuba
I've always had a connection to like
Spanish culture yeah I went to Cuba
specifically because there was no cell
phone service in Cuba but you can't he
ever winter so you can tip you know you
got to be in a hotel or some pimps or
like burner phone that was right around
Cuba with and I was there for a month by
myself just driving around talking to
myself like I'm unhappy what am I doing
with my life like what am i doing for
the rest of my life look I need to marry
something right now that I'm gonna do
forever
and I've been playing the piano since I
was 10 I was I wrote it out but when I
was 16 years old at that point I'm like
I'm just gonna spend every [ __ ]
minute that I have just learning
everything there is about music because
I think I've always had this talent
right I can play I've always been able
to play and sing and whatever but I'm
like I'm gonna really [ __ ] refine it
and master and I'm still in that process
it's funny the whole time you've been
talking I'm like this kid's gonna make
it impact cuz he's gonna do the music
thing it's gonna work he's gonna become
big and then he's gonna wake up at 33
and he's gonna be like what the [ __ ] now
yeah
and I need to go through it to wake up
100% but you already know that's exactly
what's gonna happen
I don't know I'm telling you right now I
know you know that's gonna happen
obviously you could die from a heart
attack but but but I think right right I
think it's but the reason I'm pushing on
this a little bit it's an important
thing to know i I get at 24 and even
just humility which is usually what
people understand this humility is
usually the answer to buy someone
successful I just think it's interesting
to calibrate that self belief as well
but never letting it actually have any
more energy than the humility but not
letting it have less either because the
truth is the only thing that is actually
meaningful and so like if you truthful
it like I truthfully believe I'm gonna
be unbelievably a pack full on the human
race both through my selfish and
selfless acts that one could consume
that'd be like what a [ __ ] what you
know like cool but if it's my truth I
can't not say it because then you're
sandbagging and sandbagging is also you
see where I'm going
more importantly if you start Cal a guy
that's willing to [ __ ] ride a bike
and walk on beaches for a month in Cuba
to talk to himself is an interesting
character and a good one meaning it's
crazy how much I talk to myself I talk
to myself more than I do anything else
even when I'm not talking about
basically doing it now I'm always in my
[ __ ] self awareness right I just think
it's important for you to be okay which
sometimes having a conversation with
yourself that looks like this when I'm
one of the biggest artists on Spotify in
seven years and touring in this and that
when I wake up in my parents home or in
a hotel in Costa Rica or in New York
City or LA when I wake up and say oh
[ __ ] I have that feeling again that
that's awesome not bad
absolutely absolutely I've evolved
already through so many lives from the
time
was like sixty years old that means all
inevitable hey my god nice meeting man
well we'll get connected
babban you should join us so let's make
it a trip that you're out with me
team a I'll toss you soon okay Pullman
hey look how are ya
well we're gonna put music over this
vlog but like that secret wine project
show a little clip from back in a day
for everybody who's just catching it
[Laughter]
back in the day three weeks ago I want
to go through the full transition there
you can stop right there like I want you
to go through the full transition of
like it's like I want to do some of that
stuff I want to see my show people that
the utter lack of no stopping I think
it's kind of interesting maybe you can
hack with that for the episodes you work
on think they're I don't think people
understand because I didn't I didn't
realize people actually take these big
breaks in between things that's what you
normals do what about you you take a
break you have a meeting and then like I
don't know you take 15 minutes before
your next thing we're chat about it like
gonna reminisce about the meeting you
just had right left I don't know like
right you do not have 40 beginning
center day
[Music]
hello are you
Alexa that's gonna be you're gonna be
dealing with that for the rest of your
[ __ ] life hi great thanks for coming
how's it going so far
fantastic you film some [ __ ] outside
when I walked in this morning a little
bit yeah I saw that
that was to do that film do you write
yeah I was like that dude some dudes
like filming outside our office I'm like
he's definitely here for four days cool
so uh lunch guys go around and and just
tell me your name which oh now we have
name play you guys are really loving
left this for disha there's nametags on
the press and give me like a briefly a
sense of what your business is about and
then we'll go back around and do
one-on-one questions and we would take
advantage of it so all right brand is
everything yeah right which is why the
answer to this question is really
Facebook if you give a [ __ ] about three
years from now not twelve months from
now right if you work in a big
corporation or mid side paper or if your
short term thinking you're gonna spend
the fourteen dollars a lead on Google if
you're smart and you think your kids are
gonna run your hotel because you want it
to be in the family forever you're gonna
make as much content that's valuable to
people as possible and create the right
accommodations because that's the only
thing that supersedes transaction the
only thing that supersedes transaction
is brand that's super-complicated always
the risk of making a fifty thousand
dollar video that becomes Dollar Shave
Club or where's the beef for just do it
is always the answer it's just hard
what if you go over five you just spent
two hundred fifty thousand dollars I'm
making five videos that nobody gave a
[ __ ] about you can't do that on Google
AdWords cuz even that even if you pay
$29 a lead better than you know what I
mean that's why people lose they make
the short-term decision because the
short-term decision has no risk you know
you're taking my opinion from when the
book came out have you looked at my last
30 posts on my last 60 posts on
Instagram I'm either zero or five max
there we go
this is the most dangerous this is why I
hate writing bugs that's why so I keep
telling people but I day trade attention
they'd literally like I will never give
better advice than to watch what I do
you go look at my last 70 [ __ ] posts
I mean sir
Instagram right now I don't have
hashtags but what I was doing it that
was the right thing to do
I'm serious I don't know what to say got
it that's why this game is so tough this
is why I changed it the day trading
attention it's day trading I don't know
how they [ __ ] you know I don't know
day trading was super well and I don't
know how people bought stocks back in
the day but here's what I know it's
faster now like I don't know my little
lean my opinion on snapchat could change
tonight right wanted listening who do
you remember I call this the high school
party rule I haven't used this one in a
while I mean you never heard this have
you I think this is the most interesting
move in high school culture if you're a
min tier popular person you can't be the
coolest and you can't be a nerd and off
the grid you have to be somewhere I
would call it lower middle class as the
prime spot like in the rank of 300
coolest kids in your class you are 200
you're below the middle if you're lucky
enough that your parents don't give a
[ __ ] or travel too much or something
else in your environment if you were
able to somewhere between sophomore and
junior year of high school host the
party and get everybody to come to your
house and [ __ ] on your house but you
held it you go from 200 to 90 to 213 if
you look at every high school if you
think back to your high school the
person that was not necessarily built to
be popular freshman year who hacked the
system was the one that realized that if
they hosted the party it would elevate
their brand within the ecosystem the
high school party rule that's what I
want you to do as a media company if
you're hosting the podcast in a very
small niche and you're the host and
you're reaching out and saying hey Rick
number one successful commercial real
estate personality in all of Texas I'd
love for you to be up
guests on my show feel like oh [ __ ]
got it yeah whoever can host the party
first wins the land grab all right it's
called right I'll be back I'll be back
thanks guys I'll be back thank you I
really appreciate it
let's do it all right what's up
everybody and welcome to the hashtag
celebrate Columbus show my name is Josh
Burnett and this guy doesn't need any
interest in any introduction to the
whole world but just in case in Columbus
if you haven't heard me talking about
him all the time this is my hero
this is the guy who inspired the hashtag
celebrate Columbus show because of the
hashtag askgaryvee show this is our
hundredth episode this is a big freaking
deal I really want to help our city
become known as the best place to live
work and raise a family in Indiana work
how would you do that in a social and
voice in the way that I inspired you to
do this show you need to inspire
everybody to just vlog and story tell
about how amazing your town is I also
tell you if we get 10% of the Columbus
and you have it like residence to flat
out just tell how great their floral
shop is how great their backyard is
interview the principal it will just
work so it's it's it's less about what
should they do it's more about can you
get momentum to inspire everybody to do
what you're doing got it cuz I've been
there wet yeah I want it to not just be
a show but I want it to be a channel I
get it on Facebook they need to produce
you gotta get people comfortable with
producing content who don't think of
themselves as content producers Karen
right now doesn't think she's a director
like Steven Spielberg but she has this
yeah and she could just be like look how
good this cartoon is so there's so much
thank you so much that bhai that's a
celebrate one where my dog upstairs
actually a really cool space it's just
two brothers yep
okay what's up baby of it such a
pleasure
good really good man smells [ __ ]
fresh in here smells good
this is great man how long guys been in
this space that's real cool before
before you bring your guys career so
like what was happening with you guys oh
I love this [ __ ] you know honestly the
origin story is so important
so before we to go over here this was
owned by two other guys interesting so I
started here as an intern really yeah
cuz I fell in love with everything that
was going on here my facebook Tim I
wanted to be I wanted to learn so I was
like you know what I'm gonna leave my
job I'm gonna learn this and dive in
dived in and I crushed it my first two
months they got ready to people to hire
me as basically an apprentice I really
started learning another detail
learn it on the you know or in
Greenfield and different method box down
tailors in New York City we're really
starting to understand the crap so we
long story short you know I build
clients I really got a lot of people who
you know respected me and understood my
eye we had an opportunity in 2016 to
take over and the original guys were
ready them to something else yeah it was
kind of ready to do something else about
striking when that yeah
agree with you more yeah because we have
this cool thing that's like a men what
about what about a pot what about
becoming a media company what about my
thesis what a little bit that's the
right concept for you if you're not
gonna go the attention route and I have
empathy for that like you know what's
funny about me I'm a tool belt I'm like
it's a wrench you're like my cool I'm
good [ __ ] it's a hammer like to me
that's why every conversation is easy
for me because it's it's just a tool
belt am i cool cool next
[Music]
for action maybe action I like it I like
it
alright we'll be in touch thank you
thank you all right I'll see you guys
later
good day three more meetings going to
one kind of private clubs where he can't
fail them so don't see those see ya
you